hello my name is Rafael Ramirez and the
senior research fellow at Oxford in
long-term futures I also chaired the
Global Agenda Council on a strategic
foresight together with my colleague
learning chunk from Singapore I've been
asked to comment on whether China will
pull us out of the economic crisis part
of the problem is who is us certainly in
China they don't seem to have very much
of an economic crisis I just landed here
from India where the growth is going off
steam so if US is Europe then we don't
seem to count for very much is if us is
the West we do seem to count for
something I found it impossible to fly
directly from Mumbai to Beijing no
direct flights so the flights from
Mumbai and from a gene seem to go
through the West but not to each other
and I think one of the big challenges is
what kind of relationships or China and
India have in relation to each other
there will be more people in India in
2019 than China if current trends
continue so India will matter as much as
China in the mid to long-term and I lord
I know from scenario planning that it is
very difficult to think about the
long-term when you are caught in the
midst of a turmoil as we have been in
Europe and
the United States in the last
twenty-four 24 12 months I think that
the question is what kind of role will
China and India have in relation to each
other and how that plays out going
forward and we should think in 10 and 20
year term horizons rather than in two or
three year term verizon's thank you very
much